we are taking calls at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47 50
we're gonna go next to our caller from
the 3 0 1 area code caller from 3 0 1 go
ahead hello the david pakman show yes it
is you're on the air
hi my name is Tolu I'm a long time
listener I wanted to ask you on the the
what I call the debate between how the
media portrays racism and sexism for
example with the whole me tube moving
it's been going on for about six months
or so I'm a huge fan of the movement and
there's a very national listen in order
to address the issue but when it comes
to black player protesting police
brutality you have places like Indiana
who are literally there's a bill out
there that will make the NFL refund
patrons money if NFL protesters protest
so I'm just trying to say it's like how
can we get it so that when when people
protest police brutality it has the same
effect as the sexism and all and that's
what's going on I'm not sure I
understand the question do you mean how
can the movement against police
brutality be as effective as the
movement against sexual harassment has
been I guess yeah I mean I would
question how effective the movement
against sexual harassment has been right
I mean I think that it like you I think
that it is a good movement and I think
that it's a good thing that we've been
hearing these accusations come forward
about so many people men in positions of
power who have allegedly committed and
some of admitted to having done a lot of
these things but I don't know that big
picture I mean it's still an endemic
problem in society so I don't know that
I'm yet ready to say it's been the major
success that that you're pointing to it
being I don't know what do you think Pat
I think it will be a success and it may
take a generation to see that come to
light yeah because I think people now in
positions of power are gonna be a lot
more weary about abusing their
subordinates knowing that it could end
their careers and the public could find
out about it I think one thing Tolu for
me would be
in both cases you want to be very
careful to not to prevent a backfire
movement in the sense that would the me2
movement there's the risk that the me
too
in cases where it doesn't really apply
will devalue the the instances where it
does and cause a sort of rebound of
skepticism which we don't want because
we've been fighting against the movement
that is by definition disbelieving of
allegations of sexual assault so I think
when we talk about police brutality it's
really important to make sure we have
the facts on our side so we did a whole
deep dive investigation into well what's
the truth about police and their
treatment of non-white men in the United
States when it comes to the probability
or propensity to shoot non-white men in
interactions and dividing those into
interactions where there has been a
violent escalation and there hasn't it
cetera so I think that in both movements
the key thing is you want to carry it
forward consciously in a way to prevent
a backfire movement that would at will
actually be counterproductive for you in
the long term okay thank you when each
one give a shout-out to Pat alright Pat
is here that's loving it that's gonna
take a vegan shot of wheatgrass for you
just just to say thank nobody off-camera
though very much off-camera of course